okay today I'm going to talk to you
about homologous series homology series
is a family of molecules they have the
same general formula and explain more
what that means in a minute two
phonology series that we're going to
look at alkanes and alkenes now within a
one of the homologous series the massive
important thing that we need to know is
they share similar chemical properties
chemical properties now what that means
is they will undergo very similar
chemical reactions for example this
homology series of alkanes they all
react with oxygen to produce carbon
dioxide and water in combustion
reactions so they all share that they
all have that in common
they share that chemical property
whereas let's say the alkenes a chemical
property that they share is they will
all react with bromine so as you can see
they undergo similar chemical reactions
because they're in these particular
groups these are two halogens different
hollingers series right here what we can
also see from the table is physical
physical properties properties vary so
the physical properties vary if we have
a look at these alkanes this shows the
first five alkanes that's called that
one methane has got one carbon atom then
two carbon atoms three carbon atoms for
covering up those five carbon atoms so
as you can see as the chain lengths the
number of carbon atoms increases so does
the boiling point so that's a physical
property the boiling point of a
substance is a physical property so as
you can see that varies within the group
whereas the chemical properties are the
same they all still would undergo
combustion reaction
with it this homologa series that
alkenes we could see these the first out
of five alkenes again as the number of
carbon atoms increases so does the
boiling point so again we could see
there's a difference in the physical
properties between the between the
different molecules in the homologous
series but the chemical properties
remain very very similar okay now at the
beginning of the video I mentioned about
this thing called a general formula now
what that means is they basically all
follow a particular pattern and we'll
see what that is right now so the
pattern that these alkanes follow for
example is cnh2n plus two now this looks
a bit complicated but it all it means is
however many carbon atoms there are
there are double that so two times that
number of carbon atoms to find out
hydrogen atoms plus two so let's just
have a look at an example let's imagine
if I had an alkane so another molecule
within this homologa series that had 10
carbon atoms to find the number of
hydrogen atoms I'd have to do to lots of
that 10 so 2 n which is 20 and then plus
2 so I'd have 20 to visit what it means
by a general formula that will always
follow the same pattern so I could
always figure out what the formula for
an alkane is because all of this
homologous series have the same general
formula the general formula for alkenes
is even more straightforward
it's just cnh2n so again because they
all have the same general form they all
follow the same kind of pattern let's
imagine if I had an alkene that had
let's say 10 carbon atoms to find the
number of
hydrogen atoms I just have to do two and
so I just have to do ten times two so as
you can see they within a single
homology series they have the same
general formula they share similar
chemical properties the big difference
between the different molecules within
homology series are the physical
properties that may well vary
thank you